so on june 23rd many of us probably got
alerted on our phones that john mcafee
the man i'm sitting with right here at
his place in 2018
in tennessee had committed suicide
allegedly committed suicide
this is the 2016 libertarian
presidential candidate this is the
wanted fugitive
this is the founder of mcafee antivirus
that he sold for 100 million dollars his
network was 100 million dollars
years later it was sold for 7.7 billion
dollars
playboy crazy videos flamboyant strange
documentary about him
committed suicide one side said there's
no way in the world this guy committed
suicide because he talked about on
twitter
the other side said he absolutely
committed suicide because he owed so
much money
to tax evasion so many different
challenges he was facing
there's no way in the world he was going
to face it now i want to give you my
perspective many of you sent me tweets
the interview i did with them three
years ago this one right here has picked
up in the last week for obvious reasons
i'm gonna give you my experience with
how
i was sitting down with john mac if you
so this interview
is at his house okay i'm in tennessee
i'm meeting with the economist arthur
laffer while i'm there
mario gets a phone call from his team
saying
if you want to sit down with john mcafee
this is the address
you need to be here in two hours we get
the address it says 125 miles away
we get in the car we head over to his
place
when we get to his place i sit in the
car mario and our shooter at the time
luis get out of the car they go inside
they're being frisked
the entire time i mean pretty intense
highly skeptical paranoid environment
ak-47s everywhere semi-automatic weapons
everywhere
led by former marines former navy seals
former rangers
who are there mario calls me while
they're setting up these guys are
watching who they are
mario says pat please come inside it's a
very uncomfortable place no problem i
get out the car i hang up with tom i was
on the phone with tom
i get inside and they start saying who
are you
said i'm patrick david are you with the
fbi
i'm not are you with any uh
organizations out there i am not
how can we believe you tell them about
your background we're not going to tell
you about your background so listen i
used to be in the military
were you really what was your most i was
a 63 bravo where were you stationed at i
went boot camp at
south carolina fort jackson i won aitf
for jackson south carolina
i was at the hunter first airborne
division down the street from you two
hours away from me fort campbell
kentucky i went to this club who would
you
what clubs did you go to in nashville
tennessee silverados you know all these
things i told mix factory
okay man it's okay come on in do you
want to have a drink with us hey what's
up i'm like
do i want to have a drink yeah come on
in they're carrying the ak-47 by the way
uh if you want there's uh five
prostitutes upstairs if you want to go
before you start the meeting you want to
have a good time
you can go upstairs and come down and do
your interview i said listen i
appreciate the offer thank you for your
hospitality
maybe ask the guys out there but i'm
totally fine
no problem if you still want you can go
upstairs i'm like i'm gonna be okay i'll
be fine
anyways we do the interview he comes in
john's coming in when he comes and you
hear the sound garage is coming up like
something
very very loud he comes in we sit down
we do the interview if you watch this
here this is john next to me was having
a drink he was smoking cigarettes while
we're doing the interview
that's a gun right there and here's what
happens
43 minutes into the interview someone
knocks on the door this has never
happened in my life when i interview
people
watch what happens right here this is
pretty random 50 different options
even direct flights from hong kong to
ecuador why they have somebody knocked
us
through um russia
the guy comes out takes out the gun so
um
so i you know it's hard for me
to say is it good is it bad i don't have
all the facts and neither do you and
neither goes back so now i'm listening
to him
talk while i'm looking seeing what's
going to be happening to my right
seeing another guy run up all these
sounds you're hearing behind you
obviously this was a very highly
skeptical paranoid semi schizo
which he even himself said some people
say i'm extremely paranoid
i am extremely paranoid he said in many
different interviews
and then when we left very nice very
amicable
we took off we did our thing the
interview went live and now it's got
many views and a lot of people are
commenting on it look before i get into
john's tweets which couple of them are
quite controversial
let me kind of give you an idea how he
got here number one he's in belize
living in belize at one point
and he has a dog that's barking really
loud the neighbor gets up says listen
you got to kind of tell your dog to be
quiet john's like he can do whatever he
wants to do dog the neighbor gets upset
takes a piece of beef throws it over
poisons the beef the dog eats it dies
jon comes home sees the dogs loses his
mind hires somebody comes and kills the
neighbor
the neighbors found in a pool full of
blood john escapes
not much happens there tax evasion
issues that he has tennessee owed four
million dollars of taxes they say he
avoided
because he said in 2018 or 2019 i
haven't paid taxes for eight years
because of ideology ideological
differences with the irs i shouldn't
have to pay taxes
and then he had a crypto dump pump and
dump issue that took place
anyways it's a very interesting
character we're talking about here this
is not a normal
human being in a normal life that he
lived this is a story from the sun just
kind of showing you who he was this is
himself
with the guns he liked guns he liked
prostitutes he likes drugs he like
partying hardcore this is a video he did
which is a
very very strange video on youtube's got
like 10 million views nearly
anyways he liked women he partied
hardcore this guy was 35 years old today
he'd be one of those guys with 20 30
million followers you can pretty much
see what's going on here this is him
talking about the fact that the
government tried to poison him and kill
him i'm more difficult to kill than
anyone else can even possibly imagine
anyways all of this stuff leads to his
tweets this is one of his tweets that
just came out
that people are talking about there's no
way he would have
killed himself getting subtle messages
this tweet is from november 30th 2019
getting subtle messages from the u.s
officials saying in effect
we're coming for you mike mcafee we're
going to kill yourself meaning we're
going to kill you
but it's going to you killing yourself
it's not suicide but we're going to kill
you
i got a tattoo today just in case if i
suicide myself i didn't
i was whacked check my right arm whacked
here's another tweet because in october
of last year 2020
while he's in barcelona on his way to
istanbul he gets arrested in spain they
take him to jail
right afterwards he sends this i said
i'm content in here jail
i have friends the food is good all is
well now if i now
that if i hang myself allah epstein it
will be no fault of
mine okay then he has this tweet that
comes out and sir resurfaces from june 9
i've collected files on corruption in
government for the first time i'm naming
names and specifics
i'll begin with a corrupt cia agent and
two bahamian
officials coming today if i'm arrested
or disappear 31 terabytes of
incriminating data will be released to
the press now
when you look at this you have two sides
to look at let's say he is right
he has those 31 terabytes a lot of data
on government officials
that could be pretty ugly especially
with campaign election all of that stuff
that you got going on
nobody wants that to be seen but the
other part of it is also he's bluffing
what is bluff
there's an old fable about a psychic who
hooks up with a king's daughter
the king loses his mind sends all the
soldiers
to go kill the sidekick when the
soldiers go to the psychic and they say
we're here to kill you the psychic says
before you kill me
i had a vision last night that has to do
with the kink and it has to do with his
life
i have to tell him this or else he's
going to die like what are you talking
about
the soldiers talk and they say let's at
least tell the king and see what the
king wants to do
they tell the king king's like i want to
meet this guy the psychic comes to the
king he says king i have to tell you i
apologize
for getting together with your daughter
she's beautiful however
the vision i had yesterday is that you
king are going to die a day after
i die which means what if you kill me
you're dying tomorrow so the king's like
you know back in the days it was all
like psychics know what they were
talking about
and people were very superstitious the
king's like listen we better take care
of this man he brings a psychic in he
lives in the palace obviously it's a
fable
but you get the idea is john playing
that game hey
leave me alone don't bother me don't
touch me with my taxes because
i have stuff on you because i'm such a
good hacker is he doing that
no one will know what cardi is playing
here he may or may not have it but this
led to a story
after john passed away allegedly suicide
and this is what the story went viral
there's a tweet that they're showing
and claiming that he tweeted out says if
anything ever happens to me
please know that the 31 terabytes of
files i have are located on hard drives
in my condo near 88th street and collins
avenue just north of miami beach
which is the building that just came
down
and there's nine people dead and 150
something people missing
the conspiracy theorists ran with this
saying oh my gosh
it's government's job it came down they
got the files now nobody can get their
hands on the 31 terabytes
this was so viral with people being
curious about it that ap did a story
saying
that never happened he never owned the
condo and there's no tweet
as such of him sending it out on june
8th so i go and take a look at his
twitter account
and if you go look at his twitter
account you go to june 8th there is no
such thing as these tweets the only
things you'll find on june 8th there's
one he's talking about have a million
followers and no one's really bothering
to look at it
and another one about basil's there's
nothing else on june8 now
the conspiracy folks will say well
twitter can delete it i highly that they
did that
so ap departs that and they don't touch
it it goes to completely different
places anyways this goes to a bunch of
different places
you know all these other things and then
janice mcafee his wife sends out a tweet
talking about on father's day june 20th
the fact that they don't want to do
anything with this guy the government's
so corrupt
the u.s authorities are determined to
have john dye in prison to make an
example of him for speaking out against
the corruption within the government
agencies
the media continues to vilify him for
their narrative and there's no hope for
him
ever having a fair trial in america
because there's no longer any justice in
america
you either play ball or get aft there
are those
those are literally the only options now
before you were innocent until proven
guilty now somehow it's changed to
guilty and to prove an innocent
interesting point
now anyone can level the most hideous
accusations
against you without
any proof and having no basis in reality
but in the court of public opinion you
are tried convicted found guilty in your
life
irrepair irrepre irreparably destroyed
all before having your day in court
anyway so she goes on talks about this
and there's a bunch of other things that
she talked about video he would never
commit suicide he would never do this he
would never do that
a lot of this comes to me where people
are like well did he commit suicide he
would never commit suicide
chris hitchens who was a famous atheist
everybody
the many christian pastors would say
that rumor has it that on his deathbed
he accepted jesus christ as a savior
right
and he's gonna go to heaven because even
an atheist eventually accepted it
and it was a very good story to use it
was viral because people were
using that as a way to baptize folks
right i heard a lot of different
churches
but his son who was there apparently on
his deathbed said my dad and i never
talked about religion and that never
happened
and chris hitchens even said way before
he passed away if you ever hear a story
that i accepted christ as my savior or
my deathbed because i was so scared
about what's going to happen after life
do not believe it i will never do that
semi similar to what mcafee says if i
ever commit suicide that never happened
anyways we can go to a lot of different
things to talk about what happened here
these are my thoughts about john mc this
is what i think about with john mcafee
and my experiences of being around john
mcafee number one
extremely paranoid uh extremely
skeptical
even the interview if you've not watched
the interview of him and i some of the
stuff he says
i mean you're just gonna sit there and
say what's he talking it's
very deep and he doesn't hold back about
going after the government look last
week
i did an interview with a
mayor you may know mayor giuliani was an
attorney that you may know
rudy giuliani who in 2015 won the g-man
award
by fbi as one of the most best man for
america fbi awarded him the g-man award
in 2015.
we're talking six years ago and the
interview is about three and a half
hours it was done at his place
and he said some stuff that i still
don't know if i'm going to go live with
or not
you know i had a i had a group of people
that had a call with yesterday and they
know about what was in the content of
the interview telling me pat
don't go live with it today because this
is just not a good time
to go against the government look what's
going on right now with censorship i'm
like but it's not me doing it it's
someone else doing it i'm simply showing
what their thoughts are not pushing back
on what the individual had to say just
don't do it pat it's not a good idea
because today it's censorship they can
do this they can take you down
just last week we had one of the videos
we did about one professional athlete
that had certain things to say about a
health restriction
and we posted on our vitamin short clip
channel we got a strike for one week
the channel was suspended of uploading
any new videos so there is an
element of people being concerned about
not really sharing everything today
because social media companies out there
can really push back right so
i don't know did mcafee have things to
say that was really pushing back a
little bit too much against the
government
was he poking the bear too much could
that possibly take place
there are some times where i grew up as
an individual
where i believed everything i started
off with mainstream media what they had
to say and i would watch them i'm like
you know what
nbc's right cnn is right you know
msnbc is right these guys know what
they're talking about new york times is
right
and all these conspiracy theories they
have no clue what they're talking about
wasting time they're just doing this and
then there's some people that say well i
start off with conspiracy and i go to
mainstream media
here's how i'm wired i like to hear both
sides of the argument
i want to know what they have to say and
in my mind i'm like i'll give you 10
of credibility conspiracy theories but i
also listen to what the media has to say
and fyi i also only give 10
credibility to mainstream media i take
it upon myself
to want to do some research to get some
info for myself
so everything i shared with you today i
don't know if you committed suicide
i don't know if it was a job that was
taken because they wanted to take them
out on 31 terabytes of files
based on what some of the things this
guy had to say and who he was as a
person
as a genius as a guy that's like a
modern day if he was younger he'd be
like the guy from iron man you know
tony stark he was that kind of a
character he built a company that was
sold for 7.7 billion dollars
he just so happened to sell it pretty
early so having said that
that's my reaction to john mcafee dying
on june 23rd
if you haven't seen the interview that i
do with john mcafee
click over here and watch it for
yourself fyi
if you think it was a hit shop
and somebody else took him out press
thumbs up if you think
he committed suicide press thumbs down i
am curious to know what you think
happened to john mcafee having said that
have a great week everybody take care
bye
[Music]